[MUSIC PLAYING]
TRUDI MCCANNA: Hi everyone.
My name is Trudi McCanna,
and it's my pleasure
to welcome you to today's
Talks at Google event featuring
best-selling author, educator,
and consultant Rachel Simmons.
As the mother of an
11-year-old girl,
I've been a big fan of
Rachel's for a few years now.
And I found her work
invaluable as I've
worked to understand and
help my daughter navigate
the challenges of
growing up today.
And let me tell you,
there are more than a few.
I've also been a
little bit surprised
to find that Rachel's
lessons and teachings have
been so relevant to
my own life, because--
shocker-- it turns out the
challenges that girls face
don't just stop at the
end of adolescence.
So really happy Rachel's
here to join us today.
A bit more about Rachel.
She is "The New York
Times" best-selling
author of the books "Odd
Girl Out" and "The Curse
of the Good Girl."
Her most recent book, which
she'll be talking about with us
today, is "Enough As She Is -
How to Help Girls Move Beyond
Impossible Standards of
Success to Live Healthy, Happy,
and Fulfilling Lives."
Pretty cool.
Rachel is also an educator.
She consults
nationally on women's
professional development, and
is a national spokesperson
for the Always Like a
Girl and Keds Brave Life
project campaigns.
She was the host of the
PBS television special
"A Girl's Life," and her writing
has appeared in the "Washington
Post," "Atlantic Slate,"
and "The New York Times."
Rachel is a regular contributor
to "Good Morning America"
and appears often in
the national media.
"Odd Girl Out" was adapted into
a highly acclaimed Lifetime
Television movie.
Rachel co-founded the national
nonprofit Girls Leadership,
and that's actually
very important,
and important as
an organization,
because what it does is
it takes the research
and work that she's
done, and puts it
into actual,
practical application.
We're lucky that Simone, who
co-founded Girls Leadership
and is the executive director,
is here with us today.
And we'll have the
opportunity to learn more
about that amazing
organization as well
at the end of Rachel's talk.
We will have some time for Q&A.
For those of you on livestream,
there is a Dory available.
It is go/rachelsimmons-dory.
And for those of you
who have books in hand,
Rachel has kindly
offered to stick around
after the talk at the back
of the room to sign them.
With that, please join me
in welcoming Rachel Simmons.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL SIMMONS: Thanks, Trudi.
Thank you.
Hello, it is a pleasure
to be with you today.
I want to thank Google, and
Google Talks, and Trudi McCanna
for putting this together.
So I want to talk with you
both as potential parents
in the audience, but
also as individuals.
Because as Trudy said,
there's no question
that a lot of what I write
about not only applies to girls
but applies to grownups,
applies to boys and men.
And I have had that pointed
out to me many, many times
over the last four weeks.
I've been touring this
book all over the country.
Today's actually the last
day of my tour, so woo-hoo.
And so yeah, so I really--
and if I'm honest, so
much of what I write about
comes from personal
challenges that I myself
have been navigating and
trying to make peace with.
And so with that, I
encourage you to listen
with lots of different hats.
Today, what I'd like to explore
with you in the 30 minutes
or so that I have to talk
with you are three things.
One is to talk about ways
that the culture has changed
for girls since we were teens.
Two is I want to be a translator
for you of some of what I would
say are the more toxic messages
about success that girls are
getting, because I think it's
very important that we as
advocates for girls, as
educators, as teachers,
as parents, that we learn
how to talk back to some
of those messages, so
that we can shield them
from those messages.
And finally, what are the
skills that you both need.
Meaning you, both
parent and girl,
need to help her redefine
success in some healthy ways.
So let's start off with a couple
of changes that have occurred
since I was younger, although I
kind of want to start with even
an earlier change,
meaning something that's
been around for a long time.
And I'm going to ask the
members of the audience
to do a brief exercise.
I promise there won't be
anything else after this.
You could be totally
just hanging out.
But if you could,
sit as you would
imagine a typical guy
sits in his chair.
How do you--
OK, so everybody-- for those
he live streaming, everybody's
manspreading right now.
Everyone is spreading out.
And then how do you think a
typical girl sits in her chair?
There's no more laughing,
just if you can't hear.
The typical girl posture--
everyone is starting
to contract.
Everyone's sitting up
straight, crossing their legs,
looking like they're
being watched.
And yeah, you guys were
totally manspreading
during the man thing.
And I love that
activity because I
think it illustrates what
people would call gender norms--
some of the unwritten rules
that girls and guys grow up
with about how you're
supposed to act.
And what I also like
about that activity--
and it's a great one to
do with your own family--
is it allows us
to think not just
about the space that guys
might be given to take up
with their bodies, but
also with their voices,
and their opinions,
and their appetites.
Because when I ask you
to sit like a girl,
everyone suddenly gets smaller.
And so there are also
messages that girls
get about the permission they
should be taking up or not
taking up, the space that they
taking up with their
voices and their opinions.
And why does this matter?
Well, it matters
because, in addition
to this pressure that girls get
not to take up too much space,
we have also said to
girls, hey, guess what?
You can go do and be anything.
So we've said to
girls, would you
like to go now be an engineer?
Fantastic.
Would you like to
go work at Google,
and study cognitive
science, and do robotics?
Absolutely awesome.
What we haven't done is
we haven't said to them,
but you don't have to worry
about being liked anymore.
You don't have to worry about
pleasing others anymore.
having that perfect bikini
body anymore.
What psychologists call what
girls are facing right now
is role overload, which
basically means too many roles
for one person to play.
Role overload is linked to a lot
of stress, as you can imagine.
You may be surprised--
or not-- to learn
that adolescent
girls get the least
sleep of any group of youth.
And I honestly think
that this is in part
due to the expectation
that you not just be smart,
but you also better get one
like per minute on Instagram.
God help you if you don't.
You also need to be
involved in activities.
You need to be
captain of a team.
And that is fatiguing, it
leads to early burnout,
and it also creates what
researchers call role conflict.
So in other words,
in a 24-hour day,
what it takes to have the
bikini body that you want--
I keep saying bikini body
because if you open up
Instagram--
even this week, there's a lot
of young people on spring break.
And I actually
follow a lot of them.
And luckily, they usually
forget that I'm following them,
so I can learn.
But there's a ton of
bikini pictures coming out.
And it's all about look at
me, and look at my body.
And it's a very specific kind
of body that's being shown off.
And what we're finding,
actually, in the research
is that--
whereas it used to be that
when I was 100 years ago--
a teenager--
and I wanted to look at
somebody's cute little body,
I would have to go
to the grocery store.
I'd have to buy a magazine.
I'd have to look at a celebrity.
What's different for girls
is that all you have to do
is open your phone.
And not only are you going to
see the bodies of celebrities,
but you're also going to see
the bodies of your friends.
And that can create, and
that is creating, body shame.
That is creating concern
and a loss of confidence
in their own body.
So these are some of the things
that are really different.
Another thing that I would
call as different as what
I like to affectionately
call the college application
industrial complex.
And by that, I mean the
very intense pressure
that girls face almost from
middle school at this point,
this sort of message they
get that if they don't craft
themselves into the most perfect
specimen worthy of college
admission, they are going
to lead mediocre lives.
They really get this
pressure that they
have to be absolutely amazing
at everything they do.
And if they don't, I don't
know, cure a major disease
in their science project
in middle school,
they're going to leave
very unhappy lives.
And what they feel is that
their whole worthiness
is kind of riding on
that day, whether or not
they get accepted into the
college of their choice.
And I think what it's doing
is it's sending them some very
toxic messages about success.
One of them is the expectation
that they be amazing
at everything that they do.
What can you say to girls--
and, frankly, to ourselves--
about this expectation?
I mean, first of all, there's
absolutely no way that we can
be amazing at everything we do.
No way.
And in fact, if you
expect yourself always--
what I do with girls
is I sort of say,
if you always expect
yourself to be up here,
you are invariably going to
feel that you are not enough.
You will feel that
you are less than.
You will feel that you,
in the moment as you are,
are not worthy.
And it is impossible
to try to be
amazing at everything you do.
And when you try, in addition
to feeling that self-criticism,
the other thing that
happens is that you feel
like you can't take any risks.
And as I speak at a
place like Google,
I feel like Google is all about
taking risks, asking questions,
being curious.
And if you feel that
you have to play it safe
because you can't mess
up, because you've
got to get that
perfect resume, you've
got to have that perfect GPA,
your muscle for risk-taking,
your ability to comfortably face
uncertainty, that will atrophy.
And I think what we
want for our girls--
if you really want
to be brave, you
have to regularly put yourself
out there in small ways.
I'm not a big believer in
the Eleanor Roosevelt saying,
"Do something every
day that scares you."
Because I'm kind of like, who
wants to be scared every day?
Do you guys want to
be scared every day?
I'm not down with
that, personally.
No, I would like to be a
little nervous every day.
I could do that.
I could get with that.
That was my long-winded
way of saying
that comfort with risk-taking
happens through small things
that we do all the time
to challenge ourselves.
When girls are
trying to be perfect,
they lose comfort
with risk-taking,
and it diminishes their courage.
The other thing that happens
is what I affectionately
call a mass nationwide
adolescent hallucination,
that all my friends are doing
and being more than I am.
In other words, girls are
often taken with the sense
that obviously all my
friends are smarter than me,
all my friends are
doing more than me,
they're cooler than I am.
And I think it's super
important to talk
to girls about the kind of
futility of that attitude,
because the reason why
you think everyone's
doing more than you is
because you don't feel enough.
If you're trying to get up
here all the time, of course
you're looking over your
shoulder, being like,
who's coming up behind me?
One of the most
common questions I've
been asked on the
road for this tour
has come from girls
who come to my talk.
And they say, what am I
supposed to do about the fact
that I don't feel happy for
my friends when they succeed?
What do I do about
the fact that there's
a competition between me and my
friends where I don't feel good
about it, and we're
not talking about it,
and it's eating away
at our relationship?
Now, I think this
is a warning sign
in terms of when we think about
women supporting other women.
If girls are operating
from a belief
that even their
friends are potentially
threats to their own success--
again, stemming from that sense
that they are not enough--
what does that
mean for how women
support each other later on?
So there are quite a few--
I wouldn't call
them side effects,
but there are real
consequences to what's
happening around the culture
in terms of that pressure
to be admitted to a four-year
college or university.
So what are some things you can
say to the girl in your life
who might be struggling?
I have been totally blown away
by how much the following makes
a difference to a
teenager's well-being.
Saying to them, I don't think
this is your fault, what
you're going through.
In other words, a lot of
teenagers-- girls and guys--
who are overwhelmed
by anxiety and stress,
they're very convinced that--
what's wrong with me that
I can't overcome this.
What's wrong with me
that I can't keep up.
And to say to a
teenager, you know what?
What's wrong has very
little to do with you,
and much more to do with
how broken this culture is
around achievement and
success, and the pressures
that it's putting on you, it's
transformative for a teenager.
And I don't want to
oversimplify my work,
but I do believe that when
you can make a teenager
feel like they're not the only
one suffering from something--
and I think we all can feel
the benefits of that awareness.
But when you can tell
her, this isn't just you,
it makes a huge difference.
The other thing I
think we need to say
is we don't want
to tell them, why
are you guys putting so
much pressure on yourselves?
I know I was told that many
years ago by my parents.
And I actually wrote an article
in the "Washington Post"
about a month ago
about this very thing.
And in it, I really
call on parents
to stop telling their kids
that they put too much pressure
on themselves, and here's why.
When you say that to a
kid, the implication is,
if you could just
chill, everything
would be fine, because
it's just all you.
You're just doing this yourself.
When, in fact, we know--
and hopefully I've
convinced you somewhat--
that this is a cultural issue.
This is something
much bigger than what
one kid is doing to herself.
And it's actually much
more helpful to your kid
to hear that everybody
is struggling right now.
And you could have a
really peaceful home.
Let me be clear.
You could have an amazing
house that is like super zen
and very spa-like, and you
really are putting pressure
on your kid.
And I totally believe
you that you're not.
However, the second your
kid walks out of your house,
she is flooded with that stress.
So it's not about what
she's doing to herself.
I want to talk about
impostor syndrome right now.
This is a picture of Maya
Angelou, who is obviously
a giant of a human
being, and a writer,
and a poet, and so many things.
She has been very public
about her struggle
with imposter syndrome.
And she believes and
has said that she
has this abiding fear
that at some point
she's going to be found out.
And when she's found
out, everyone's
going to see that she's not
nearly as smart or as talented
as everyone thinks.
Well, one of the great surprises
of my research with girls
has been the extent to which
imposter syndrome is with them
from a very early age.
In fact, I discovered
research that
said that it's firmly
in place by adolescence.
I work on a college campus, and
I ask my students all the time
to finish this sentence.
I say, sometimes I worry
that I'm not as blank
as other people think I am.
And I've also started
doing the same with adults.
The most common response, the
most common fill in the blank,
is I worry that I'm not as smart
as other people think I am.
So what do we say to our kids--
and to ourselves,
because, my goodness,
I also struggle with
imposter syndrome for sure,
and relatively frequently.
I was going to joke between
meals, but not that frequently.
But a lot.
When that voice comes
up inside of us, when
we hear that voice that says,
you don't deserve to be here,
you don't belong here, you
don't have what it takes,
we have to talk back to it.
And we do this in two ways.
One is we realize that this
voice is a voice inside of us,
but it's not the
voice that is us.
It's not you.
It's the small, scared part
of you that rears its head,
but it does not
mean that it is you.
So we really need to teach not
only our kids but ourselves
that that's a
recurring part of us,
but we don't
over-identify with it.
And the second thing
you do is you name it.
I have one student who named
her imposter voice Lester,
which I thought was hilarious.
And so she'd be like,
yo, Lester, I got this.
You step off, OK?
Like, Lester, I hear you.
I hear you telling me
that I'm not smart enough
to be in this AP class, or
I'm not whatever it is enough.
Chill, dude.
Just have a seat.
And so when you talk back to--
and you name-- that voice, it
actually gives you an ability
to separate yourself from it.
Gratitude is a very
powerful practice
that research tells
us does everything
from help us sleep
better at night,
boost our immune systems,
and elevate our wellness.
And basically, what
this sounds like is
a kind of simple
acknowledgment, which
you can do any
time, of what it is
you are grateful for right now.
It does not have to be epic
or polished or important
beyond I'm happy
the sun came out.
You know what I'm grateful
for today, honestly?
I was staying in Mill
Valley last night
because I spoke
there for my book.
I woke up.
I didn't have time to
go to the gym, which
was five minutes away, and
there was a terrible storm
here last night.
And somehow it stopped raining,
and I got to go run outside.
And a few minutes after I came
back in, it started pouring.
And I just took a
moment and said,
I'm so grateful that I got to
get my heart rate up today.
That's enough.
When we can, in small moments,
say this thing that happened,
that's enough for me, it
allows us to be on the ground
instead of going up here.
It allows us to affirm
what matters right now.
But we also have to be
willing to buy into the fact
that the small things count.
And I think a gradual
practice-- and I
want to say practice because
it's just like that muscle
that we have to flex
for risk-taking.
It's just like the
do something that
makes you nervous every day.
We're not talking about
becoming like a zen monk.
We're talking about
you're driving to work.
What are you grateful for?
Just stop and think about it.
And this can open up
something inside of you--
a place of appreciation
that can make you
feel enough in this
very moment right now.
And it's been very powerful
for me and my young daughter
as well.
Well, I hope it's
powerful for her.
I might just be hallucinating,
but I'm hoping that it is.
There are a couple
of things that I
want to cover in this talk
beyond some of the smaller
pieces of advice that I've given
you that are, in the research,
considered very palliative
factors in adolescent wellness.
One of them is purpose.
So what's purpose?
Having a sense of
purpose in your life
means that you do
something that you're into.
You really like doing
this, pursuing this goal.
But this particular goal or this
thing that you're involved in
connects you to something
bigger than you.
It's not like a
self-oriented goal.
So let's just think of
something purposeful, something
that makes an impact on
the world in some way.
I mean, it could
be volunteering.
It could also be
creating an app.
It doesn't mean that it has
to be public service oriented.
I was on a public radio show
in the Bay Area yesterday.
A caller phoned in
and talked about how
his daughter, who had
been riven with anxiety,
discovered juggling.
And once she
discovered juggling,
she began traveling and juggling
for underserved children,
and that this healed her.
And that's a sense of purpose.
She was part of something
bigger than herself.
Contrast that with
the kid who says,
my goal is to get good grades.
My goal is to be accepted
into a brand name college.
My goal is to score a
perfect score on the SAT.
People who are driven
by self-oriented goals
tend to be less happy.
They also tend to
be less resilient.
I'll tell you who else,
actually, just to--
I want to deviate
from this purpose,
or digress from this purpose,
conversation for just a moment
to say that there are two
other differences that I
want to talk with
you about in terms
of types of goals you pursue.
So Carol Dweck, who is
a psychologist based
at Stanford University
who studies motivation,
talks about the difference
between pursuing a performance
goal and a learning goal.
Now, a performance goal is when
you undertake something because
of the approval that you
might get from others,
or because you wish
to avoid failure.
A learning goal,
which-- spoiler alert--
is what we want girls to
have, and what we should all
be trying to pursue
more than anything,
is when you undertake
a goal because you're
trying to master something.
You undertake this
thing because you really
want to learn about it.
So for example, I want to
master the past tense in French.
That's a learning goal.
I want to get an A in French
is a performance goal.
Now, there's nothing wrong with
performance goes on there face.
It's totally fine
to want to strive
for attention and reward.
But that can't be the primary
thing that drives you.
Definitely not.
Because for those people
who are driven primarily
by performance goals, they
are also less resilient.
They are also more unhappy.
Now, why are you
less tough if you're
driven by a performance goal?
Well, think about it.
If what is driving you
isn't coming from within,
isn't inspired by a
kind of genuine desire
that comes intrinsically
from within you,
it's so much easier
to knock you over.
So you have a setback, and
because you're more invested
in what other people
think, it's so much easier
to get knocked over,
because you don't
have the grounding
in your own desire
and in your own motivation.
So what that means for you
as parents, or for yourself
as you pursue your own
goals, is to say, hey,
am I doing this
because I want to?
Or because I feel
like I have to?
Are you taking that class,
you could say to your kid,
because you really want
to learn this thing?
Or are you doing it because
you think it looks good?
And again, nothing wrong
with wanting to look good,
but that can't be the
primary reason why.
A purposeful life is
on the decline in terms
of goals of adolescents.
Adolescents are increasingly
saying, I want to make money,
I want to get a great job, and
I want to go to a good college.
The percentage of
students who say,
I want to lead a
meaningful life,
has experienced a steep decline.
And researchers believe
this is absolutely related
to the decline in
wellness in teenagers.
When you are with your daughter,
and if your daughter-- or you,
honestly, because what I'm
about to say absolutely
comes to my own mind as I
stand in the face of a risk.
But if you want to get your
kid to do something that's
challenging to her, if you
yourself want to take a leap,
there are three questions
that work really well.
One is, what do you think the
worst that could happen is?
And I want to
clarify here, girls
are particularly
good at telling you
the absolute worst
thing that could
happen on a catastrophic level.
And so I want to
just sort of amend
this by saying actual
worst that can happen,
not catastrophe worst
that could happen.
Because girls are such
good catastrophizers.
And then, can you live with it?
So for example-- and I say
this, too, because I know
a lot of girls who don't
want to take risks.
They don't want to raise
their hands unless they
have the right answer.
They don't want to
try out for the play
because they're afraid
they won't get a part.
They have application fear.
I don't want to
apply for that job
because I'm afraid I won't
get it, or that internship,
or that fellowship.
And so we say to them, what
is the worst that can happen,
and can you live with that?
It's very rare that
I have a student who
says, no, I can't live it that.
Most people, once they
really are willing to look
the consequence-- not the
catastrophe consequence,
the legit one--
in the eye, they're like,
yeah, I could live with that.
Another question that has
been profoundly helpful for me
personally is, as you stand
in the face of a challenge,
a risk, you're going to put
yourself out there in some way,
you say to yourself, what is
the minimum benefit that I
could get from this thing?
What's the least good
thing that could come out
of this experience?
And I feel extremely strongly
about what I'm about to say.
If you want yourself-- or
if you want your daughter--
to resist perfectionism, we
have to help them appreciate
the beauty of the process.
We have to help them appreciate
that there are always
unanticipated benefits,
lessons, moments of inspiration
and wisdom that come
when we least expect it,
that come when the big moment
of glory doesn't arrive.
So that even if you
don't get into that play,
or you get a crappy chorus
part, and wow, that's a bummer,
and I'm sorry, there
are other benefits
that come from this experience.
You make new friends.
You learn a new skill.
You learn that you
can stick stuff
out that's not what you
thought it was going to be.
I think that when
we all imagine--
if you think to yourself, what
in the face of an obstacle
have I learned?
What from a heartbreak
have I gained?
We ask ourselves this
question as adults.
The same kind of wisdom
will accrue to our children.
We have to have
faith that it will.
I think as parents,
you don't want
them to be suffering, right?
We don't want our children
to be in anguish in any way.
And yet the same wisdom
and strength and courage
that we have gained
from our own obstacles
will also come in due
time to our children.
And we have to have
patience with that,
create space for that.
Because ultimately, if
all we are driven by
is the big polished
finish, is the outcome,
is the college essay-worthy
moment, then of course
our children will be
addicted to perfection.
Two more things I want
to say before I hand it
over to Simone Marean
from Girls Leadership.
Parents need to practice
what psychologists
call self-regulation just
as much as our kids do.
Just as much as
we expect our kids
to keep it together, we also,
as parents, have to do that.
And that's because it's really
hard to watch our teenagers
goes through the ups and
downs, the chaos of this time.
So here are three
things you can do.
One, remember she is
still watching you.
I say this because
teenagers are exceptionally
good at acting like they
do not care at best what
you say, and think you're
clueless and stupid at worst.
And it's very
important to remember
that even if you think
your child doesn't
want to connect with you
anymore, it's not that.
It's the way she
wants to connect
with you is deeply
unsatisfying, often is the case.
I'm just going to be assuming
that one here is laughing
on the inside about that one.
But anyway, I still
think it's funny.
Thank you, Trudi, for laughing.
Anyway, my point is that
your teenager is absolutely
still connected to you.
They still want to
know what you think.
And the way that you
react as a parent
in the face of a problem, they
are absolutely downloading.
They are mimicking it,
too, in the sense that--
just like they used to mimic
the words you say when they were
little, they are now
starting to mimic
how do you respond to
distress, how do you respond
when things don't go your way.
They are watching us.
And we do have to be careful
with how much anxiety we
bring into our
conversations with them.
Number two, share your mistakes.
Do not imagine that being a
good role model to your kid
is about acting like you
never do anything wrong.
When you do that, when you don't
tell them about your setbacks,
they think that
it's not OK for them
to experience them themselves.
And worse, or
maybe related, they
become afraid to tell you
about their own mistakes.
Number three, ask
yourself this question.
And this is a shout out to
Sheryl Sandberg's question
and "Lean In," when she posed
the question, what would
you do if you weren't afraid?
When you stand in the face of
deep anxiety around your child,
when you look at something
that's not going well,
and you say, this
thing happened.
What if this means blank?
Because I think parents can
also catastrophize, right?
We can also say something
went wrong here.
What if this means
globally that she's not
going to make friends?
What if this means
she's not that smart?
What if this means she
doesn't go to a good college?
As parents, we have
to check ourselves.
We've got to walk that back down
away from the global anxiety,
down to what's really happening.
And one of the best ways to
do that is to ask yourself,
all right, if I knew that
everything was going to be OK,
if I knew that whatever
is freaking me out right
now about my kid was
going to be fine,
if I could practice
faith and optimism,
if I were not afraid, how would
you parent if you were not
afraid?
The choices that we make in that
moment when we're not afraid
are so much wiser.
They are choices we're much
more likely to be proud
of than when we make choices
from a place of fear,
and what if, and what does
this mean, and anxiety.
The last thing I want
to introduce you to
is self-compassion.
Self-compassion is a second,
strongly research-based
palliative factor
for adolescents.
It is the practice of
being gentle with yourself
in the face of a challenge.
Now, many people think that
gentleness with yourself
in the face of a
challenge is not
only a way of being
lazy about your problems
but also could result
in complete paralysis,
because who would possibly
be motivated if they weren't
being mean to themselves?
These are all common
responses to self-compassion.
Responses I should say
I had myself for sure
when I first encountered it.
In fact, what self-compassion
is about is not
pretending that
something didn't happen,
or taking responsibility.
It's basically about saying,
yeah, something happened.
I don't feel good
about it, but I'm not
going to trade away my
self-worth in the process
of dealing with it.
I also want to add that research
shows that self-compassion does
not diminish motivation,
and it doesn't
diminish performance standards.
So here's what it is.
Here's how it works.
There are three steps that
were developed by University
of Texas at Austin Professor
Kristin Neff who has a book
of the same name,
"Self-Compassion,"
a wonderful website--
of course, a TED Talk.
And the three steps
work this way,
and I am going to teach
them by telling the Google
world about something
that happened to me,
and how I learned to
practice self-compassion.
So the first step
is mindfulness.
Now, several years ago, I was
really, royally, and radically
dumped.
And I went into a total tailspin
about what this meant about me.
So I am also an excellent
catastrophizer--
recovering now.
So I went into this
place of, obviously,
I'm a broken human being who's
going to die alone with dogs.
Not cats, because
I'm allergic to cats,
but I think you
get my reference.
And clearly nothing
good will ever
happen to me again in my life.
So that's not mindful, right?
Mindful is not catastrophizing.
Mindfulness means, all right,
something bad happened.
What do I really feel right now?
What is my actual emotion?
Not the denial or
the catastrophe.
I feel sad.
I'm grieving.
And the next-- well, this
week, probably the next year
is going to be
really hard for me.
The second step
of self-compassion
is self-kindness.
This is hard for
a lot of people.
Deceptively simple.
And this basically means if you
had a really close friend who
you loved who was being mean
to themselves in the way
that you were being
mean to you, what
would you say to your friend?
Because the reality
is, aren't we
so much nicer to other people?
We show other people
so much more grace
than we show ourselves.
So this is a thing.
I also do this, by the way,
by channeling one of my best
friends, who I call my
unicorn friend because she's
like so much nicer sometimes,
I think, than I am.
I'm like, why are
you friends with me,
because you're so nice?
Do you ever have a
friend like that?
I call her my unicorn friend.
Trudi actually knows her.
And I imagine what my
friend Daniela would say
to me, because she's so nice.
And I think, what
would Daniela say?
I've got to say that to myself.
And then the third step
of self-compassion--
another really powerful step--
is common humanity.
And what that
means is, are there
other people who
might be suffering
the way I'm suffering?
Am I the only one
who's ever been dumped?
Thank you, Google, for telling
me that heartbreak advice gets
1.5 million hits.
Google was
instrumental in helping
me understand I was not alone.
So thank you, Google.
Seriously, I promise
you, I did this.
And when you know you're
not alone, it is so helpful.
The feeling of aloneness and
isolation that so many of us
have exacerbates shame.
It makes us not want
to solve a problem.
And so reminding ourselves we
do have a shared experience
of suffering, we are
not by ourselves,
is absolutely powerful.
So following these
three steps, I strongly
encourage you to practice this.
You can do it in the
middle of the night.
If you ever wake up, you had
an extra glass of red wine,
you woke up at 2:00
in the morning--
I'm not saying I've
experienced that personally.
Of course I have.
And you walk yourself
through these three steps.
You walk yourself,
and you practice, just
like you practice risk-taking.
Just like you
practice gratitude.
The bottom line is
that we all have
to be able to access why
we are enough as we are.
And one of the best ways to
do that is to ask yourself,
what about me is
valuable and of worth
beyond my external
standards of success?
Beyond my salary,
beyond my position,
beyond the accomplishments
that I may want to share,
or that I think define me?
What beyond those standards
makes me enough as I am?
And when you know that,
you can be stronger
than you ever thought possible.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So I'd like to turn over the
mic to Simone Marean, my dear
friend, my colleague, who is
fiercely committed to making
sure that every girl, no
matter what her income
level or background, has
the power and the skills
to exercise the
power of her voice.
So I want to introduce
everyone to Simone,
the CEO and co-founder
of Girls Leadership.
SIMONE MAREAN:
Thank you, Rachel.
Our mission at
Girls Leadership is
to equip girls with
the skills to exercise
the power of their voice.
And we see this as
the foundational skill
of leadership no matter
what a girl wants to pursue.
Whether it is coding,
or business, or arts,
or government, and all the
places where we want our girls
to have leadership.
And I would like to
say, before telling you
briefly about who
we are, that I am
so grateful to be
back at Google,
and grateful for the support
of Googlers' contributions
and the matching
program here, which
has made such a powerful
difference in our work
every year-- at Girls Leadership
particularly-- in our ability
to serve girls and schools
in low-income communities.
So thank you for that support.
What makes Girls
Leadership unique
and the girl-serving space
is really three things.
One is that we are the only
organization to partner with
the adults' and girls' lives.
What we have found is that
when we teach a girl the skills
to exercise the
power of her voice,
but she goes back to a
school or to a family that
doesn't support that and
doesn't understand her voice,
that what we teach
can be undone.
But if we work with the girl--
not only the girl but also
her parent, her teacher,
the caregiver, the auntie,
the nana in her life
who's giving her
scripts every day
and giving her
permission, that's true,
sustainable change.
So of the 10,000 people that
we teach in person every year,
over 5,000 of those are the
adults' and girls' lives.
The second thing
that makes us unique
is that we are really grounded
in emotional intelligence,
which I think is
so much of the work
that Rachel's been talking
about-- the social, emotional
learning.
These invisible skills
and processing that
is the vital foundation
of the external skills
that we want them to
demonstrate in academics
or in the workplace.
And so our belief
is that if a girl
knows what she thinks
and feels and needs,
and she respects it--
that's the hard
part that many of us
lose over the course
of adolescence--
and she has the ability
to express it effectively,
those three things will provide
that foundation for her.
The last piece that
really makes us powerful
is that we see girls' everyday
relationships as her incubator
for leadership.
So rather than
saying to the girls,
if you are chosen as
captain of the team,
if you are president of the
class, then you are a leader,
and you have influence.
We are instead saying to girls,
leadership is a way of life.
You get to decide in
the countless decisions
that you make every day whether
you're going to have influence.
When you decide how you
look somebody in the eye.
Do you raise your hand in class
when you don't know the answer?
when you do know the answer?
Where do you sit at lunch?
A high schooler
recently reminded
me, do you eat lunch was a
leadership question that she
had to face every day.
Where do you sit at lunch?
All of these countless
decisions are opportunities
that girls have to build this
self-awareness and agency
and ability to make change.
So those three things--
emotional intelligence
is the foundation,
adults are our partners,
and everyday relationships
are the incubator--
are what makes
Girls Leadership who we are.
And right now, we're focused
on two strategic initiatives.
One is that we
are looking deeply
at the experience of
girls and women of color,
and really trying
to understand how
does race, ethnicity, and
income level impact gender
expectations.
Because what we're finding
is there's very different
experiences that girls
have in different cultures.
And if we can gather the
data on that difference,
then we'll be able to reach
the 25 million girls in the US
where they are across those
infinite differences that
exist.
So that's the first
thing that we're doing.
And then we're also very much
focused on educator training
as the vehicle to
scaling our curriculum.
Reaching each girl one
by one is a slow process.
But if we can reach the
educators, the administrators,
the principals, the people
that have power over hundreds,
if not thousands,
of girls' lives,
that's how we can really move
the dial quickly in the US.
And so the last thing
I would like to say is,
we have a couple
Googlers on our board.
But if anyone would like to
be involved and participate
in this work, we are very
grateful for the partnership
and the support of many.
Like Trudi McCanna has been
here over the years for myself.
So please reach
out to me if you're
interested in being involved.
Thank you.
Great, thank you.
OK, let's go to Q&A. If you
have a question in the room,
go ahead and head to the mic.
And we will be watching the Dory
for anybody who has questions.
Again, it's
go/rachelsimmons/dory.
TRUDI MCCANNA: Oh, great, we
have a question in the room.
Let's start with that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thank you very much,
Rachel and Simone.
My question might be--
either you an answer, probably.
My question is about--
so I observed this
tendency among-- so I have
an eight-year-old girl myself.
And I observed this
tendency for her
to quickly identify
her BFF at school,
and sort of constrain
her relationship
with this small
number of friends.
So even if she is sitting next
to another eight-year-old girl
that she just met today--
if she was a boy, then I think
there's more tendency for them
to kind of play along
with others, as long
as this kid is well behaving,
but my girl wouldn't talk.
So I'm not sure if
this is good or bad.
Caring more about
relationship is good,
but not expanding it is bad.
So I'm not sure how this
will pan out in her future.
So I wanted to
get your thoughts.
RACHEL SIMMONS: I think
this is a Simone question.
SIMONE MAREAN: The BFF thing?
RACHEL SIMMONS: Yeah, Do
you want to come up here,
and we'll do a
little duet on the?
SIMONE MAREAN: Songs
I don't have to sing.
RACHEL SIMMONS: Will you
sing "Islands in the Stream"?
No?
SIMONE MAREAN: Yeah,
I mean, there's
incredible pressure on
girls to find that BFF,
and to find her on the
first day of kindergarten.
And it's at eye contact, and
there's rainbows and glitter,
right?
RACHEL SIMMONS:
My Little Ponies.
SIMONE MAREAN: Yes, jump around.
And the cost of that is--
the BFF rules are basically
you like all the same things,
you do everything together,
and you never fight right?
Any of us as adults, if we can
imagine a 24-hour relationship
where we like all
the same things,
we do everything
together, and we never
fight, this myth is the
biggest setup of all time,
because of course all those
things are going to happen.
So I think it is important
that we dismantle
that myth for girls,
and we really teach them
what healthy
relationships look like,
and how to navigate
disagreements,
and how to make
people feel included.
I have a six-year-old
son, and it's still
every day giving him
scripts and teaching him
about the impact of his
relationship choices.
And so when he doesn't talk
to that person next to him,
how does that make them feel?
And I call it
leadership behavior.
When you have influence, and
when you reach out to somebody,
and when you're
inclusive, what's
that change that you're
making in the world?
And that they can take on that
bigger label and that bigger
meaning of their actions.
So it is important to look
at that myth and that gender
expectation,
dismantle it, and help
her build the full set of
skills to connect with people
across a range of differences.
RACHEL SIMMONS: Couldn't
have said it better myself,
so I hope that was helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TRUDI MCCANNA: And we do have
several questions on the Dory.
All right, so our top
question right now on the Dory
is from Hillary.
And she asks, how can
parents lay the groundwork
for these skills in
younger children?
RACHEL SIMMONS: I'm so happy
you asked that, Hillary,
because I'm also the
parent of a younger child.
And you may know the
common phrase, little kids,
little problems, big
kids, big problems.
And so by that, I take from that
little kids are so much more
impressionable and a little
bit easier to work with.
So what are some things you
can do with a young child?
One, you can make the
practice of gratitude part
of every breakfast.
So every day breakfast, what is
one thing you're grateful for?
And you say it, and they say it.
Again, one of the
benefits of doing this
with younger children
is that, as they proceed
into the eye-rolling
years, they at least
have this groundwork
that's been laid,
which helps keep them
much more connected.
You have a much better
chance of hanging on.
Another thing you can
do is talk with them
about the way they
talk to themselves.
So if you're physically
comfortable going to a place
where you could maybe jump
over something with your child,
like, for example,
bouldering, climbing on rocks,
or walking by a
creek and stepping
on the rocks in
the creek, and you
sense your daughter
anxious about something--
and I'm using the
creek as an example,
but there are all
kinds of things
we might do with our child
where she feels afraid
when she's young.
You say to her,
it's a good thing
to talk to yourself in
a positive way, to say,
I can do this.
Teach her what internal
self-talk sounds like.
This is certainly something
my daughter has absolutely
internalized, and who
is almost six years old,
and who does this frequently.
Another great thing to do is
when your daughter is working
on something that's
challenging for her,
and you can feel her starting
to either get frustrated or want
to walk away from
it, you go up and you
give her tons of praise,
and you say, look
how far you've gotten at this.
Look how much
you've done already.
And that's known
as process praise.
Process praise is about
making sure kids feel really
good about being in the
middle of a challenging
process, making sure they feel
praised for sticking with it
and being a part of it,
as opposed to waiting
until they've finished and cross
the finish line, as it were,
to give them the praise.
We know from research that--
and I find this
amazing that they've
been able to figure this
out, coming out of Stanford--
that even in toddlerhood,
boys get more process
praise than girls.
Which is unbelievable to me.
And if you hear process praise,
if you are praised for--
another way to ask
this is, let's say
your kid is working
on something,
and you say, tell me about
the strategy that you used.
And by the way,
teach them the word
"strategy," because strategy
implies there's always
more than one solution.
There's lots of different
ways to do something.
So what kind of strategy did
you use to figure that out?
And they can get excited about
what they've done so far.
So all of this helps
make kids braver
because it means they don't
have to perform at the highest
level.
It means they know
you care when they're
in it and in the
process and trying.
So those are all
things that you can do.
There's so much to do
with younger girls.
AUDIENCE: So first I want to say
I'm currently reading "Enough
As She Is," and one
of the struggles I'm
having is reading it as both
being and as [INAUDIBLE]..
Like, still being growing
up, and kind of trying
to view it from maybe
how my mother felt
about me growing up.
And something that
my mother and I
have been talking about
and trying to work out
for a long time is the
fact that it didn't so much
matter to me what she said.
It mattered to me what she did.
And I would just
mirror her behaviors,
even if she was telling
me the opposite.
And as somebody who struggles
with things in my own life,
I wonder if you have
any advice on if you
know you have a problem, and you
participate in a behavior that
would be very damaging to mimic,
and yet you're still struggling
yourself to not
do it, how do you
communicate this with somebody
who might be watching you
as a role model?
RACHEL SIMMONS: That's
a great question.
So meaning you have
awareness of the behavior
that someone is mimicking.
Well, of course, the pat answer
is do as I say but not as I do.
But I think you're pointing
to something deeper,
and something
that's been studied,
actually-- it's just
beginning to be studied,
which is the way that
young people can tell
the difference between what
their parents' values are
and what their
parents actually say.
So in other words, teens
have a great BS detector.
They know that their
parent might say,
oh, I really want
you to be happy.
And they, at the same
time, know their parent
is very committed
to them getting
into the best possible
college, which may actually
contraindicate their happiness.
And so I think
that you're really
highlighting something that's
quite new in the research.
But, of course, your
question is about how
do you relate to somebody when
you know that you're modeling
something that's not healthy.
And I guess I
think the kind of--
I know Bren Brown was
here at Google yesterday.
I think vulnerability--
authentic vulnerability--
is really important.
So to be able to say almost
as part admission of what's
going on but also
part apology, if you
believe it is called for.
I know on a smaller scale
that in the moments where
I let my own child down,
when I fail my own child,
whether it's because I have
yelled in a way that wasn't
appropriate or called for,
or I have been too dismissive
or distracted, I catch
myself, and I say,
I'm really sorry
for what I just did.
And she'll say,
it's OK, it's OK.
I think she gets like, Mom,
please stop being awkward,
because we live in New
England, and she apparently
has no feelings.
Anyway, she's like,
please stop, please stop.
And she's only six, but I try to
say to her, this wasn't right,
and I need to make right.
I need to meet it right,
I need to make it better.
I don't beat myself up.
So it's a combination
of that vulnerability--
that authentic vulnerability--
but also being willing to
be accountable, and to say,
I don't have it all together.
And it goes back to
what I said earlier
about the importance of making
mistakes in front of your kids,
because your kids need to know
how to screw up as much as they
need to know how to succeed.
You can't know how
to succeed truly
well if you don't have the
tools to make mistakes.
And yet so many
of us as parents,
we err too much on
the side of we're
going teach how to succeed.
And that's really part of
what this book is about.
I'm a big fan of
the book "Lean In."
And I believe what
we need to teach
our kids to do is to lean
inside so that they have
the tools to be
strong and to navigate
the barriers and the
unforeseen moments that arise
when they are pursuing success.
TRUDI MCCANNA: Great.
We have another
question on the Dory.
This one's from Elizabeth.
She says she's currently reading
"The Curse of the Good Girl,"
published in 2010, specifically
in regard to part two,
Breaking the Curse.
Is there anything
you'd update or advice
you'd modify based on things
you've learned and observed
since it was published?
RACHEL SIMMONS: Wow, that's
a really good question.
Well, I guess yes, absolutely.
And I actually talk about
this in "Enough As She Is."
That's a wonderful question.
Yeah, I kind of realized
that I screwed up
a little bit in "The Curse of
the Good Girl." so Elizabeth,
mea culpa.
And if you decide
that you like my work
enough to read the
next one, you'll
see I actually talk about this.
So in "The Curse
of the Good Girl,"
I argue that the most important
thing girls need in order
to thrive is to
break that curse,
is to not have to sit
like a girl all the time,
is to be able to speak
up and not feel like they
have to be modest
and have conflicts,
and express their feelings.
And I thought that if
girls could do that,
they would lead happier,
healthier lives.
So here's the
problem with that, is
that I was putting
way too much emphasis
on the role of the girl.
I was not at all thinking
about how toxic the culture is
for the girl.
And I think that just
stems from my own can-do--
I come from a very
immigrant family,
like, you can do it, just
bootstrap it, figure it
out kind of mentality
that I grew up with that
actually wasn't fair to girls.
The thing that
I've realized now,
almost 10 years later, is that
the data that we see around
the world, really, in terms
of what girls are facing
around anxiety and
depression and stress,
and the percentage
of girls who say
on college campuses
at the age of 18
that I feel overwhelmed
by all I have to do.
These are all
stratospherically rising.
That's not about
the girl's failure.
That's about the way
we are failing girls.
And I do think becoming a
parent changed things for me.
It allowed me to see the
things that I could control
and the things that I
can't, and that we all need
to work together to change.
TRUDI MCCANNA: All
right, another question
from the Dory from Shralika.
I apologize if I
butchered your name.
She asks, teaching kids to
be independent versus being
there through the process.
Example-- would you sit with
them passively or actively
through a homework, or
leave them to work it out
and let them ask if
they have a question?
RACHEL SIMMONS: Such
a great question.
And I think as our
kids get older,
that is the
million-dollar question,
is where is the balance between
finding that zone of struggle
and growth that doesn't
push them over the edge
and make them deteriorate
into a tantrum or whatever.
I think that is an art.
It's not a science.
I think that what
we want-- let me
tell you what we want to avoid.
We want to avoid
parenting and teaching
girls who feel like they have
to ask every five minutes,
is this right?
Is this right?
Did I get it right?
I don't know if this is right.
What happens is they
go to their teachers,
and every couple of
minutes they keep asking,
is this exactly what you want?
Teachers are now
complaining about this to me
all over the country.
It's called learned
helplessness, basically.
So it is support seeking, right?
It looks like support
seeking, but really what it is
is a fear that if I don't
get it exactly right,
oh my god, it's
going to be a crisis.
Now, that is not a muscle we
want our kids to cultivate.
And if you hear your daughter's
teacher talk about this,
it's really important.
So how do you find that balance?
Well, first of all, I
think you have to prepare
your daughter beforehand.
And you say, listen,
I know that you're
going to be doing
your homework, and I
want you to know that I'm here.
And I also watch and
know that my goal is
for you to challenge yourself.
And so I might not be
as available to you
as I usually am,
because I'm going to ask
you to grapple with some stuff.
Grapple might be a
big word for your kid,
but I'm going to ask you
to work on stuff yourself.
And I'm going to ask you to
come up with some strategies
yourself for how you
could help yourself
without necessarily using me.
So I would say to a kid, what's
one thing you could do other
than asking me?
Maybe it's to call a friend.
Those are all powerful
things that they can come up
with to advocate for themselves,
to make good on a problem
that they have, that don't
involve going to you.
Then I think you have to
find that growth edge, right?
I think that's the phrase.
You have to find that
place with her where she's
pushing herself
but not becoming so
turned off by what she's doing
that she doesn't want to do it.
Because here's the thing.
I think when kids really start
to hate what they're doing,
I mean, they hate
what they're doing.
So we also have to make
sure that they're not
getting undone.
And like I said, it is an art.
I wish I had a good hard
and fast rule for that.
Actually, wait, I have
one more thing to say.
Sorry, I did think of it.
It's hard to think on
your feet, because I'm
like, what would I really say?
So here's what I think.
I would actually
say to the kid, what
is one way that you
could challenge yourself
that you've never
challenged yourself
before in doing your homework?
That's what I would say.
Let's come up with
something that you
would do to push yourself
that you haven't done before.
OK.
TRUDI MCCANNA: All right, and
we've got one more question
on the Dory.
And I think it's the last
question we'll have time for.
And it's, again, from Hillary.
And she asks, what is your
take on single-gender education
for girls?
Are there specific situations,
personalities where
parents should consider it?
RACHEL SIMMONS: Yes, I think so.
My take on single-gender
education for girls
is that it can be
a very important
and empowering and enriching
experience for certain girls,
but not necessarily
for all girls.
There's a lot of great
research out there about--
for example, I'm thinking
of the work of Linda Sax
at UCLA, who has looked
at the difference
in self-reported
confidence levels
in the first year of college
of girls who have attended
coed schools versus
single gender schools,
and there is a
significant difference.
That the girls who come
from the all-girls school
report higher levels
of confidence,
more speaking up in class.
That being said, I think there
are wonderful benefits to being
part of a coed community.
I also think-- are there
certain kinds of girls
that I would recommend
a single-sex school to?
Yeah.
I mean, I think
about this a lot for
my own soon-to-be six-year-old.
And I think that
if she turns out
to be a kid who is very
vulnerable to social pressure,
particularly around
boys, who has a hard time
distinguishing between
what her own values are
and what the values
of her peers are,
I might seriously
consider putting her
in an all-girls school.
Because I do think
that particularly
around middle school because I
think that during that period,
the powerful,
intense expectations
to conform to what
other people are doing
can be very destructive
for certain kinds
of kids who are vulnerable.
So I'm thinking a lot about
that for my own daughter,
and watching her.
I also think that
for those girls who
need more attention around
things like leadership
development, speaking
up, girls schools
tend to be more
oriented to focusing
on what the vulnerabilities
are that girls bring.
So I would say those two
points of vulnerability, to me,
would be reason to
seriously consider
an all-girls environment.
TRUDI MCCANNA: Terrific.
Well, with that,
we're out of time.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
RACHEL SIMMONS: Thank you.
TRUDI MCCANNA: Join me in
thanking Rachel and Simone,
please.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL SIMMONS: Thank you.